coming up all the highlights from this
year's golden globes including
chadwick bozeman's poshmas win tina and
amy's best one-liners
and all the heartwarming celeb family
moments
hello everyone and welcome to et live's
golden globes after show i'm danny
directo
and i'm cassie delaura there were so
many memorable moments from
the golden globes so many that you and i
can't break them down
alone which is why we have some friends
joining us
from rotten tomatoes jacqueline coley
and et's very own leanne aguilera
now ladies before we start breaking
things down we want to avoid any
technical difficulties like the golden
globes experience so uh just to double
check
are we all unmuted and can you hear us
can you see him can you hear me now i'm
just scared
is this when i start talking
so we're off to a good start the golden
globes a different story let's get right
into it you guys
the moment that went viral daniel
kaluuya versus
the mute button i mean the actor won the
golden globe for best supported actor
uh for judas and the black messiah but
his speech was almost accidentally cut
off because
probably like so many of you during your
zoom meetings at home his microphone was
actually
accidentally muted i mean jacqueline
what did you make of this moment and
also did this kind of set the tone for
you for the rest of the night
yeah it was a little off which i guess
is kind of maybe the tone for the
evening but i did love that he had such
a great smile in that moment that's
something that i would definitely have
no matter what happened and they did
bring him back and he was able to give a
great speech but
give it up for daniel he did he did well
considering how mortifying that would
have been
well it made for a memorable moment
though and you know like you mentioned
they did get him back he did get to give
a speech um he also talked about uh
what happened and about that technical
difficulty with our very own kevin
frazier let's take a look
daniel i know that was your big moment
and
you almost missed your big moment um how
happy are you that everything worked and
you got to say your piece and
congratulate
everybody and was it your technical
difficulty or theirs how can i hear you
my guy
oh we've got a technical difficulty now
bro yeah
okay here we go i got
the best part about this is that we're
not even in mercury retrograde right now
so we can't even blame the technical
difficulties
but the best part is i was actually
getting my hair and makeup done during
this and i just
remembered there was this silence and my
eyes were shut because we were you know
putting eye shadow on and whatnot i go
are they having a technical difficulty
right now because it was just dead
silence that's exactly what it was but
you know i feel like one of the best
moments just overall of this entire
night was just the virtualness
of it all and noticeably missing though
i feel like from daniel's shot
was he had no plus one with him but it's
a good thing the stars
made up for that with uh plus ones plus
twos plus threes plus four
some fur babies some furby animals take
nicole kidman and her family for example
we got a rare sighting
of she and husband keith urban's two
daughters sunday and faith right there
but my favorite thing about this is that
we didn't have to wait for the cmts the
acms or the cmas to get a keith urban
sighting right there
also we had a lot of kids in the picture
for
mark ruffalo when he was accepting his
award
also kate hudson and her big family
the whole tribe it was a family affair
for kate and also i mean we can't leave
out the pets because pets are family
members too
we had cats we had dogs we had
everybody joining the shots right there
now leanne i wanted to ask you because
you have been
to the golden globes you've experienced
the glitz and the glam and all of its
glory was it nice to kind of see the
celebs
in a more laid-back environment tonight
definitely cassie because i felt like i
wasn't alone i'm coming to you from my
home my cat was watching me get ready
this whole time so it was just really
nice
to be able to get a peek inside of these
celebs homes
and and kind of find out what brings
them joy during this
chaotic time and who they want to
surround themselves on a big night like
tonight so it was really exciting and a
shout out to jason sedakis for his
hoodie
because all right i'm gonna want that
now
he was comfortable okay he was
comfortable and shout out to john cheeto
who called him out during his up
during jason's acceptance speech and
time to wrap it up that was one of many
very viral moments that happen
throughout the show a lot of standout
must
watch moments including also tracy
morgan messing up
soul and calling it sal that was so
iconic already
i mean jaclyn what'd you make of that i
lived for that moment especially
the fact that the guys for the next
category the lead actor comedy
the perfect group to make fun of that
were absolutely cracking joke
romney youssef and jason sudeikis were
like i didn't know odin kirk was in here
it was so great it was so hilarious you
know it was also so hilarious too going
off of the whole virtualness of the
night
cynthia nixon taking the opportunity to
make sure that she had a virtual
background right there and not just
any old virtual background she didn't
choose hawaii as her background or
anything like that
she chose the famous bernie sanders
mittens meme
right in the back of uh in the
background right there and i just i
remember watching and i'm like
oh my god that's not a plus one right
there that is that's a virtual
background
the best pro perhaps the best plus one
in my opinion but
you guys are so many other moments to
get into including of course the big
winners
of the night and we can't begin this
without talking about
chadwick boseman he won his first and
posthumous golden globe award
for best actor in a drama for his role
in ma rainey's black bottom i mean
jacqueline
it was kind of hard not to feel
emotional about this win especially
considering that his wife taylor simone
she accepted the award on his behalf i
mean what did you think of that moment
yeah such a bittersweet moment and i
want to stress the fact that this is a
posthumous award and of course that
brings an entire new dynamic to the
campaign but
he would have won this anyway this was
the greatest performance of chadwick
boseman's career which is incredible
considering the man played
everyone from james brown to jackie
robinson of course black panther but
you could tell in this performance
perhaps he knew it might be his last
because
he left it all on the stage as they say
or in this case on the screen
and so it was so incredible to see his
wife speak his words and say
who he would want to thank saying his
mother and and his god and her and his
family and it was just
it was an incredible moment and i think
uh something we're going to see
throughout this awards season
is her having these moments on stage to
honor him similar to how we did when
heath ledger had his
posthumous campaign i think adding to
the poignancy too
is us knowing that he filled ma rainey's
black bottom
while he was sick it was a year before
his passing and obviously it was uh it
was actually a surprise to a lot of his
co-stars too
you know and we actually got a chance to
talk to one of his former co-stars
angela bassett
about what it meant to be able to honor
and celebrate chadwick's life
career and legacy tonight at the globe
let's take a look
i know my you know my heart my
son chadwick is up for an award so
you know to um to just see his face on
the screen and recall his brilliance and
his spirit
it's a sweet spirit it's a sweet feeling
in my heart
you know um we we miss him terribly but
uh
he was kind of individual in the kind of
work he did
you know is is worthy of remembrance
like you mentioned jacqueline something
tells me we will be remembering chadwick
all award season long and beyond but
let's switch gears now talk about the
other big film winners of the night
uh nomad land won best drama and also
borat subsequent movie film
won best musical or comedy any of those
a surprise to you
well i did have hamilton picked on our
picks over at rottentomatoes.com but i
did put
that the only option that would not be
hamilton would be borat
also picked sasha to win for best actor
no mad lan however was not a surprise
one of the few studio films in the
conversation this year
the hollywood foreign press i think
wanted to make sure this traditional
studi
studio quiet indy got some recognition
tonight specifically chloe zhao who not
only shot the film
but also edited it as as well as served
as director so
and and wrote on the screenplay as well
i mean it was clearly a labor of love
for chloe and she was rewarded tonight
by the hfpa not just for
best motion picture drama but she also
made history by winning
best director i mean how exciting was it
to hear her name called tonight
it was incredible i mean we already
started in a landmark moment having two
women of color nominated three women
total
so no matter what happened tonight i
felt that we were going to have a
historic moment and
chloe zhao having swept most of the
major director prizes this year
was the likely choice and i think it's
going to get books very excited for her
next feature which is marvel's the
eternals it's
such a great turn of page similar to
some other sort of oscar-winning marvel
directors but
incredible film and again over 100 wins
we clock them over at rottentomatoes.com
and the film has won over 100 awards
through the various critics groups this
season
really running away with things i was
going to say it's a clear front runner
for now right
um i want to talk about one of my
favorite films of the year and that's
minari it won
best foreign language film tonight which
by the way
director lee isaac chung accepted the
award with his very excited daughter on
his lap
and i felt like you really got a sense
of like why he created this movie he
even said it was his daughter who really
inspired it
uh of course there was a little bit of
controversy with minari not being
nominated
for best drama was winning best foreign
enough do you think
well this was similar to what happened
last year with parasite it was also
relegated to best foreign language film
and unable to compete in the best drama
category however with this one
there were films that the hollywood
foreign press had previously allowed
with the similar amount of language uh
that was in english
and glorious bastards quentin tarantino
only had 30 of english either and that
was able to compete in best drama
also a film that's a true american
immigrant tale that was
filmed in tulsa oklahoma set in arkansas
it's really hard to argue how that could
be labeled as foreign
but as the hfpa tries to i think
rehabilitate some of these controversies
we might see a shift in that in the
upcoming award shows
and quickly jacqueline what other big
surprises were there for you tonight
well i think rosman pike was a big
surprise for everyone because this was a
category that i think a lot of folks had
pegged
maria bakalova for poor at but
i think um the women of that whole
moment sort of just turning to her which
is complete joy
and she's been a favorite actress for
the hollywood foreign press last year
they nominated her
for a private war that she did where she
played a war journalist
and this is now her third nominations
after golden
after gone girl so i think this was time
for the hollywood foreign press to award
this a film that's peaking you would
think
right at the right time for her to break
into that best actress conversation
and also shout out to andrea day who won
best actress in a drama for the united
states versus billie holiday
i saw that over the weekend and it was a
transformative performance
and look how shocked she was that was a
highlight for me but jacqueline stick
around we're not done with you yet but
that was just movies guys for more tv
love let's kick it over to cassie
delaura
yes from the biggest winners and film to
tv of course we have to bring in our tv
expert leanne aguilera leanne it was
a big night for shit's creek the crown
and the queen's gambit
my question for you is did that surprise
you or was your ballot money on these
these picks i will say cassie i was
pleasantly surprised to see such a regal
night for tv
from on-screen princesses to chess
queens to
her royal highness catherine o'hara we
had so many queens winning tonight
um i went of course talk about the crown
i was not surprised that this
took home best drama because you know
what this was an absolutely phenomenal
season which is really saying something
considering this is in their fourth
season
um we know of course that emma coren won
for
outstanding actress for playing lady
diana spencer
um her on-screen hubby josh o'connor
also won best actor
and then of course jillian anderson our
lady thatcher
took home for best actress in tv uh
supporting role
but i'm so excited that all three of
these outstanding actors and actresses
took home the win because this was the
only time that they were each able to be
nominated for these roles
um in season five the roles of lady
diana
and prince charles will be played by
brand new actors and then jillian
anderson won't be coming back so this is
really their only time to get this win
so i'm really excited for all three of
them
leanne moving on now to shit's creek you
and i are big fans
of kaylee cuoco and the flight attendant
and i know we had our fingers crossed
for that series
but shits creek kind of overshadowed and
took home the winds
i mean i feel like especially after
sweeping the emmys this was not really
a big surprise here i i i've got to
agree with you cassie it wasn't a big
surprise
but then again the hfpa loves to give
the awards to the new
up-and-comers so i really did think that
if there was going to be a new show that
could take it away from the
golden globes gigantic winner shit's
creek
it would have been the flight attendant
but of course i'm just so excited
for shit's creek uh they really deserved
this
and like you said this was their swan
song so very excited that
catherine o'hara was able to win despite
the fact that she had a little bit of an
awkward moment with her husband when he
was like
trying to play her off like it was a
cute bit but it just didn't catch on for
me that quickly so
props for for trying to give us that
sweet comedy moment
the pets behaved better than catherine
o'hara's husband did in that moment
now you mentioned that hfpa loves a
newcomer
the queen's gambit were we surprised
here
i was just thrilled i just loved this
limited series so much everyone was
talking about it when it came out
everyone suddenly wanted to learn how to
play chess
uh but i just think that it was such an
outstanding series and then to be able
to see
that we had our of course lovely leading
lady also take home the gold that was
just fantastic
i cannot wait to see what is coming up
next for her and i'm just so thrilled
that this is the
series that was able to snag limited
series very well said thanks leanne i
know you're sticking around to join us
uh in the meantime you can get started
on our justice for kaylee cuoco shirts
i will thanks leah silicon the globes
may have been virtual but that didn't
stop the stars from bringing
their fashion a game plus the hollywood
foreign press association addressed the
controversy surrounding lack of
representation
more on that in two minutes